good morning look it's a little cold and
wet out there so let's warm ourselves
out good morning a feather to the
graduates of 2013 congratulations one
more time you're here it and you deserve
it to hear it several times today I know
I know I'm the last thing standing
between you and your diplomas so even
though I have a great deal i want to
tell you I will be brief to everyone who
has come here this morning to celebrate
the graduates of 2013 welcome to MIT
into the parents and families of today's
graduates congratulations to you as well
it's great it's great to have you all
here in Killian Court for this
tremendously important occasion now the
last time that I was out here with a big
group of people we were having a huge
snowball fight I know that many members
of the class of 2013 were part of it to
those of you who got me wet consider
this weather as round two and I
personally invite you to come back next
winter for a healthy rematch I'm told
that before we let you graduate I'm
expected to give our graduating class a
charge that sounds to me like one last
problem set one last piece it a mite is
giving you all of you that is quite a
fun challenge I'm also told not to worry
too much about what I'm telling you as
you're likely to forget whatever I say
two seconds after i'm done so that is
yet another fun challenge I'm eager to
take on
let me start by welcoming you again to
the MIT family even though you joined
our family the moment you registered as
an MIT student for the very first time
and this is no ordinary family first of
all the MIP family is big its core
members include MIT is a hundred and
twenty-seven thousand alumni worldwide
including those over there looking
spiffy in their colorful red jackets
Vivian wait oh my god our MIT family
also includes the remarkable members
past and present of the MIT faculty as
well as our students postdocs and stuff
now as you all know this is not a family
you are born into you have to earn being
a member of our family and our big
family opens its arms to all those who
are committed and dedicated to mi peace
mission principles and values this
family you chose to join years ago has
been busy over the years members of the
MIT family have been awarded the Nobel
Prize 78 times that is over nine percent
of all Nobel Prizes ever awarded there
are only three countries with more Nobel
prizes than the MIT family the u.s. the
UK and Germany also at last count living
MIT alumni have founded about 26,000
active companies do the math that's one
company for every five living graduates
those companies provide jobs for three
three million people and they produce
two trillion dollars in global revenues
and that was before Dropbox I don't have
to tell you that our big family likes to
do big things this family is ambitious
incredibly beautifully disruptively
ambitious there is simply no place like
MIT our great family embraces many
styles and personalities I have met many
of you the goddess of 2013 in the last
few years when I've asked you what is it
that you like the most about MIT you
have answered each other you have also
told me that you did not know until you
got to MIT that smartness comes in so
many different ways so you know MIT and
you know each other very well and you
know that we all share some deep values
our commitment to excellence integrity
meritocracy an open spirit of
collaboration a strong desire to make a
positive impact and a sense of
responsibility to make the world a
better place in fact mr. Saul Khan one
of our very accomplished graduates and
last year's commencement speaker came
back here to visit this spring and he
explained that he can always spot
someone from MIT even without checking
for a brass rod because he said when you
tell them that some problem is
impossible their eyes light up that is
you that is MIT the MIT family is famous
for all these things world-famous
as you go out into the world you may
find that these family characteristics
set you apart they will make you
different and I believe they will serve
you very well as you leave us today
however I want you to appreciate another
side of MIT to it came into focus for me
this year like never before I began to
notice it last fall when a student named
Lydia k published a blog that captured
the attention of the campus she
described an intense period of sadness
and self-doubt in hundreds of MIT
students reached out to her in support I
saw this side of MIT after the Boston
Marathon attack I received letters from
total strangers who had fled the bombed
inside and stumbled into our
fraternities and sororities in Boston
and they felt compelled to write because
they were so moved by our students
generosity and kindness I also saw this
other aspect of MIT in the great wave of
support and sympathy across our
community for everyone affected by the
Boston Marathon attack then a few days
later the tragedy of the marathon
bombing arrived at our own campus and
the whole world saw what I saw the
extraordinary outpouring of respect and
gratitude for our beloved MIT police and
the loving sympathy that flowed from the
heart of this family to the family of
officer Collier I've never felt so proud
to be part of MIT
today I can tell you for certain that
the world will respect you for what you
know and for what you know how to do but
I also want the family of MIT to be
famous for how we treat people famous
for sympathy humility decency respect
and kindness I'm certain that no matter
what I say you will take on important
problems I'm certain that each of you
will in your own way on or the great
privilege we all share in being here and
I'm certain you will use what you have
learned in your labs and classrooms in
your living rooms on the playing fields
in your activities and in late-night
conversations with friends I'm certain
you will use what you've learned here to
make the world a better place yet I want
to charge you to do something else too
and this is your last piece it as you go
out into society I want you to change
the source code I want you to rewire the
circuits rearrange the molecules
reformulate the equation in short I want
you to hack the world until you make the
world a little more like MIT
more daring and more passionate more
rigorous inventive and ambitious more
humble more respectful more generous and
more kind if saltcan were here who will
advise me to tell you that this is
impossible on this wonderful day I'm
proud of all of you as i know you are
ready so now go out there join the world
find your calling solve the unsolvable
shape the future take the high road and
you will continue to make your family
including your MIT family proud to the
graduating class of 2013 my first class
congratulations
you